Bart just tosses a piece of chalk like a
dick that he is but that's not the scent
the sin is that the piece of truck
disappears five frames after it leaves
his hand look if God didn't want us to
nitpick frame by frame animation she
wouldn't have put frame advance on a
remote control
looks like Maggie's cost is around eight
hundred and fifty dollars which is
probably a sin for you know selling
children but the real problem is that
somehow this grocery store has a baby
setting in its scanner of the parts of
the Simpsons intro the change
week-to-week the jazz sax solo never
gets enough credit here's a sin off for
the underappreciated detail work of this
moment we have no grass we have grass
where the Globex corporation we'd like
to talk to you about an exciting
employment opportunity dry by slough
circles promise not to laugh I always
wanted to own the Dallas Cowboys well in
fairness Homer you didn't wait for
anyone to accept that promise good God
look at that font nothing good comes
from a font that looks like it was run
over by a lawn mower holy there's one
thing you can count on The Simpsons
doing well back in the day its satire
this town didn't give this homeless man
a job and a place to live they replaced
him with the collection box Cypress
Creek where dreams come true is anyone
gonna talk about the bubblegum pink
mountain range here purple mountains
Majesty purple come on did you notice
how the people weren't shoving or
knocking each other down
that's Lisa lost her critical eye does
she think that this Cypress Creek video
would show something like that with the
Springfield video show people shoving
each other
why would the chimney fall from right to
left in this window when the fireplace
is actually located in the entry room on
the other side for sale signs with no
contact info they would like to use your
restroom flip through your magazines
rearrange your carefully shared items
and handle your food production and
unsanitary manner now you know how it
feels
listen Appu if you don't want people
come in to your place of business then
maybe don't own a business even if we
sell the house we still don't come close
to paying off the mortgage
[Music]
today I learned that if I want to move I
can put an abandoned sign on my front
door and avoid all mortgage
responsibilities this packing job is
just asking for all sorts of trouble
unsecured television packed at eye
height check massive bathtub on top of a
wobbly table track all the Flanders
borrowed stuff placed near the back of
the truck for maximum joke convenience
check daddy well gah
bon voyage toodle-oo my turn I get the
feeling that we're supposed to find the
entire town saying goodbye to the
Simpsons heartwarming but honestly if
you leave town and everyone synchronizes
their schedules to line up on the
streets of town smile and wave at you
I'm guessing they're glad to see you go
try the papayas
they're juicy and full of Papa makes you
strong like Popeye the first sign that
this is the villain is his use of
misinformation
Eponine doesn't make you stronger helps
you maybe Albert Brooks is just riffing
but if you eat a bunch of papaya you
won't turn the pop I alternate to Jeff
Daniels and dumb and dumber and no one
wants that I can't believe it
I've done all my house working it's only
9:30 I can't believe this isn't a
mystery thriller episode of The Simpsons
considering there's a knife missing for
the knife block and just a few seconds
ago the empty space was on the right
side who has that knife and what are
they gonna do with it we never find out
relax Howard Globex we don't believe in
walls whoa whoa wall wall never hear
Mike Milken yeah no but where did the
cool people mover go it was here now on
the floor is just normal tile and sure
maybe it retracted below the tile and
some high-tech fashion but I want to see
that I also want to see the workout
equipment from the beginning of their
walk that should also be in the
background why because I'm a picky
bastard who enjoys continuity you do
know the video you clicked on right I've
been staring at the there's no me and
team poster in the background for some
time like Cameron at the Art Museum in
Ferris Bueller's Day Off I'm trying to
figure out if the creators of this
poster were truly being on ironic but
they came up with this on their own
without thinking about the letters or
they thought they were being funny but
didn't realize that there's no joke
there the image of a row captain yelling
to his fellow rowers doesn't give me any
clues either I'm gonna be thinking about
this poster all day now this website
does not exist now I'm not sure if it
ever did but I'm going to just assume it
was a fully functional hilarious website
that Disney let die when they purchased
Fox because everything is clearly
Disney's fault also originally this sign
was hilarious because back in the day a
school having its own website was
bonkers now this moment is ridiculous
because there are no security cameras
are armed guards never mind that's
actually depressing the real joke is
education
the real
is not paying teachers enough dang it
now I'm sad quick someone make fart
noises that's the good stuff right there
thanks Alberto barn is the newest
addition to our menagerie you we have
the honors putting the new guy on the
spot bark clearly makes this pit fart
with his hand nowhere near his armpit
and above his shirt sho doesn't know how
to pit fart correctly the dramatic
timing of these sprinklers is
astonishing almost makes me want to use
an Aquos X prick like a joke almost
hello mr. chipmunk you're a northern
reticulated chipmunk northern
reticulated chipmunks are extinct I mean
they never really existed in the first
place but extinction is extinction and
that's always a sin except for the
dinosaurs dinosaurs you know there's a
little place called Mary Ann's hammocks
the nice thing about that place is Mary
Ann gets in the hammock with you
Howard Brooks truly is the best and when
you consider that most of his dialogue
and this was improvised I just can't
help but give another couple sins off
you know invented the hammock Homer
while the actual origin is widely
disputed most agree that Christopher
Columbus popularized them and spread
their use and any chance to sin
Christopher Columbus must not be refused
where the homers coffee mug go in this
shot clearly holding it and both the
shot before and after ladies the
animation is lazy what's your least
favorite country Italy your friends
France nobody ever says Italy that's
progress but where is this tonight and
where is the king baby well just because
this food Bart is eating it's like a
giant Close Encounters mashed potato
Mountain and sick peas this episode is
great truly but I've never bought the
rest of the family wanted to return to
Springfield based on such silly reasons
Lisa's allergies could be treated fairly
easily Marge wants to go back because
she wants to do more household chores
and Bart wants to go back because he
misses something about school sorry
not buying it either the paperboy is
deadly accurate with his newspaper throw
or the person who delivers the
newspapers is an [ __ ] for piling
paper after paper into the grass in
front of a house that says abandon Rajic
arcturus couldn't have succeeded without
you
reading letters out loud so the audience
can hear them even though no one asks
you to do such a thing cliche yeah if
you had your heart set on the Cowboys I
guess this would be disappointed but
wasn't there an episode where Homer
wanted to be John Elway who if you
didn't know played
the Denver Broncos wasn't that another
episode where they moved away from
Springfield just say yes did you see the
memo about this make sure you click that
Bell icon but clicking the little bell
icon is how you make sure you get
notified every time we release a video
so click it box lawyer is here are you a
good lawyer and I'm an excellent lawyer
what lifelong dream Bart you're standing
in the way of my boyhood dream of
managing a beautiful country singer with
verbal warning trapped in a co2 inside
our poisonous atmosphere our superheated
oceans with rise drowning our lone heads
maybe they finally figured out clam
chowder is disgusting cuz it's basically
a savory latte with bugs in it
[Music]
never see the guys say goodbye to a shoe
and you walk around on the rug barefoot
and make fists with your toes fists with
your toes
hello mr. chipmunk there you go
sorry it's not in packages lots of cream
single-serving sugar single serving
cream